we've got breaking news that exposes
Donald Trump as a slightly even bigger
liar than we knew him to be as of
yesterday Donald Trump can now be added
to the list of Trump staffers I mean he
is sort of the main guy who met with the
Russian ambassador Sergei Kiss react
during the presidential campaign and you
might recall that during the campaign
Donald Trump repeated the repeatedly
claimed he had no contact period with
any Russian officials at all . that
claim has now imploded thanks to
articles from both The Wall Street
Journal and Think Progress we have
learned that Donald Trump personally met
with the Russian ambassador on April
27th of 2016 right before giving a major
foreign policy speech in which he talked
about how it would be really really
great to improve relations with Russia
The Wall Street Journal actually
reported on this last year back in May
but at the time we didn't yet have two
Trump cabinet members who got caught
lying about their meetings with the
Russian ambassador so it wasn't hugely
reported on this is from The Wall Street
Journal on May 13 quote a few minutes
before he made those remarks mr. Trump
met at a VIP reception with Russia's
ambassador to the US Sergei Ivanov
achieves lyac mr. Trump warmly greeted
mr. kis lyac and three other foreign
ambassadors who came to the reception
now kis react according to multiple news
reports from that time none of which by
the way are being refuted or denied was
seated in the front row it was an
invitation-only event the Russian
ambassador was personally invited to a
Trump speech on foreign policy and again
Donald Trump has insisted repeatedly
that neither he nor anyone in his
campaign was in contact with Russia
during the election we've since learned
that at least four members of the Trump
campaign Jeff Sessions Michael Flynn
Carter Paige and JD Gordon spoke with
Russian officials during the campaign in
some capacity you've probably heard that
Michael Flynn Trump's former national
security adviser has already resigned in
shame as a result of Lies he told
regarding his conversations with the
Russian ambassador Jeff Sessions the
attorney
general has been caught lying about it
former Trump campaign manager Paul
Manafort also had to resign because of
an investigation into possible illegal
payments he received from Russia
it's okay Pat to meet with ambassadors
that in and of itself is not suspicious
necessarily when you try to conceal it
and actually lie about it not once but
again and again
multiple people in your administration
and campaign that's what makes it
incredibly suspicious you could make the
critique that a presidential candidate
shouldn't meet with an ambassador though
because we have this idea of having one
president at a time yeah but in the
grand scheme of things they would have
blown over and for Donald Trump to
continue lying about it that's what's
really suspicious here because it opens
up the question of why yeah he may have
talked to other people what was the
conversation about etc it's also
somewhat suspicious to have a supposedly
hostile Nations ambassador at the
Republican National Convention which is
where Jeff sessions that's one of the
places where Jeff Sessions met with the
Russian ambassador as well as in front
row seats at Trump's first major foreign
policy America first type speech where
he talked about cooperating with Russia
does anybody see how this is insane and
I want to tell you about another layer
of insanity that's not actually being
reported I looked at a release from the
Center for national interest about this
speech and it lists Jeff Sessions in it
as an attendee this means that although
Jeff Sessions originally lied about
having met with the Russian ambassador
later it was admitted that Jeff Sessions
met two times with the Russian
ambassador his attendance at this
meeting which we have now learned about
would actually be meeting number three
between Jeff Sessions and the Russian
ambassador this was an invitation-only
campaign event
if these meetings are so benign and
trivial according to Trump's people why
not just come out and list all the
meetings instead of denying and lying
and obfuscating again and again al
franken believes that Jeff Sessions
perjured himself and we're going to deal
with that a little bit later in the show
right and Jeff Sessions claims that he
doesn't remember what he spoke about
with ambassador if there was three
meetings how could you not remember any
of the content not only did that at one
point he claimed not even remember
having met with the Russian ambassador
and then he said oh well okay he did
meet with him twice actually turns out
it was three times what did they talk
about I can't quite recall of reminds me
of Alberto Gonzales that's that that's
another Attorney General who during the
Bush years would regularly say he just
doesn't remember what happened